u.s banks are not going to get left
behind we just talked about how retail
investors are buying whales have been
buying they are holding 85 of bitcoin
has not been moved in the last 90 days
but the u.s banks are not going to let
this happen without them anyone on wall
street knows that if someone's gonna get
rich wall street's gonna make sure they
have their hand in the cookie jar and so
us bank is now announcing that they have
a cryptocurrency custody service that
will be available to fund managers the
offering will help those investment
managers store private keys for bitcoin
and a bunch of other assets they're
doing this with assistance from new york
dig ny dig ny dig however you want to
pronounce it it's a major bitcoin
investment firm and the u.s bank is one
of the first institutions to have a live
custody product available the regulation
will be all checking the boxes
anti-money laundering kyc etc but when
we start to think about the fact that
these individuals at the bank see such a
big opportunity that they not only want
to give people exposure to buy the
assets but they also are going to
provide custody service remember when
institutions come into the market they
can do one of three things they can
either buy the assets directly they can
go ahead and they can put capital into a
fund that gives them indirect exposure
they can buy gbtc or bitw et cetera or
invest in one of the private funds but
then the third thing they can do is they
can build products and services in the
industry to drive cash flow that's what
u.s bank is doing here they are deciding
that they're going to go ahead and they
are going to drive revenue by providing
services and infrastructure and custody
to this industry we've got two quotes
the first is from gunjan
kedia the vice chair of the u.s bank's
wealth management investment services
division and it says our clients are
getting very serious about the potential
of cryptocurrency as a diversified asset
class i don't believe there's a single
asset manager that isn't thinking about
it right now again this is not somebody
with laser eyes on twitter yelling and
screaming about bitcoin all day this is
the vice chair of the u.s bank's wealth
management investment services division
saying our clients are getting very
serious i don't believe there's a single
asset manager that isn't thinking about
it right now well boys and girls ladies
and gentlemen remember that when they
start thinking about it the thing they
do next is they start buying it and if
they're buying it that means demand
increases and if demand increases and 85
of bitcoin hasn't been moved of course
the us dollar price has to appreciate to
accommodate everyone that is supply and
demand if you don't believe in supply
and demand you need to go back to
economics 101. now we have a second
quote from her which says quote what we
are hearing across the board is that
while every currency might not survive
there may not be room for thousands of
coins there's something about the
potential of this asset class and the
underlying technology that would be
prudent for us to stand up support for
it and so what you're seeing is that
she's actually talking about
while every currency might not survive
there may not be room for thousands of
coins there's something about the
potential of the overall asset class and
so do not be surprised that when these
institutions come in they're going to do
their absolute best not to take a
position on individual coins we like
this one we don't like this one instead
what they're going to do is they're
going to provide infrastructure so that
they can allow for people to come in use
whatever assets they want they don't
care which coins win which coins don't
all they want is more people joining
into this industry and using their
products and so it is encouraging to see
them participating but i tend to think
that most of these organizations are not
going to go as far as to have a
principled view or any sort of sandbox
that they draw around what assets are
actually going to survive and which ones
aren't that's okay it doesn't mean
necessarily that they're going to
promote scams or do anything like that
but it does mean that they simply are
going to provide the infrastructure
they're not going to go long or short
assets they're not going to trade these
assets in many cases they may not even
buy it it's unclear whether u.s bank has
any bitcoin on their balance sheet or if
any of the executives personally hold it
but it is clear that they now are going
to provide the custody services do we
like the fact that the banks are now
getting into this or do we think that
the industry should put a middle finger
up to the banks and say we don't want
you to financialize this asset the whole
point of this is to get rid of the banks
but i think there's there's an
interesting point there right is like i
think the traditional retail investor uh
doesn't care about this at all i think
to your point they may even not want
this right and say this isn't good we
should uh say fu screw the banks let's
not make them make any money on this
asset class but ultimately i think it's
a really good thing and i think it's
something they should care about because
these are institutional buyers right
these are the guys the big boys that
come in with hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars and can
really uh change and move the market and
see and you can see price appreciate
rapidly right so anything that banks or
whoever wants to do it right it doesn't
have to be banks but anything that we
can do to cater to these players and get
their money in the asset class and give
them exposure uh to a growing industry
it eventually helps all of us right from
a price appreciation standpoint so i
think it's important to separate the two
and say hey look we may not like the
actual players that are doing this and
accommodating this and the fact that
they're making money on it but
ultimately it's going to be a good thing
for the industry as a tailwind uh kind
of going forward so i think it's
something that we should appreciate in
something that we should ultimately say
hey this is a good thing uh and we
should be happy that they're doing this
john institutions have the ability to
move markets when they get involved they
literally they're bringing in hundreds
of millions of dollars into an asset
class with a fixed supply obviously it's
going to appreciate in value when they
do that and if it makes money they're
going they're going to figure out a way
how to get their hands on it and it's no
surprise that they're getting involved
and i'm going to i'm going to guess that
we're going to see a lot more of them
get involved uh later on and kind of as
this
matures even more past this 12-year
existence that's been in and then for
the ico part look i don't believe every
single coin that exists today is going
to exist in 15 20 30 years right so you
have to be careful about which asset
you're picking and not group them all
together we saw that with the icos in
2017 but i think there's going to be a
few asset winners in the coin space a
few exchange winners similar like
there's a few banks that win today
i think it's also uh important to to
separate like this is just a service
right for banks it's nothing to do with
kind of the decentralized nature of
bitcoin or the network or any of that
kind of stuff right this is a service to
cater to institutional investors that
want to invest in the asset class so as
a retail investor doesn't really change
anything except for the price might
appreciate right so that's something
that you should uh that you should be
excited about the entire time that
bitcoin had dropped from 64 000 to 30
000 one of the easiest hacks as to why
uh i would tell people you know uh that
would ask me like should they sell
should they not say look i don't get
financial advice but are you gonna sell
your bitcoin to the nation states
are you are you really going to be the
idiot who sold your bitcoin to the
president of a country who should late
to the party are you going to be the
[ __ ] who sold your bitcoin to wall
street to a hedge fund to a bank well
guess what now here they're showing up
right and i can tell you what i'm also
not going to give them my bitcoin in
terms of putting it in their custody
products oh yeah i'm a huge believer
that there is some version of the world
uh some portion of the population that
needs access to these products and so
there's institutions there's family
offices foundations uh endowments maybe
even sovereign wealth funds uh public
companies etc they're gonna need the uh
kind of financial services of incumbent
players centralized entities etc uh that
come from the wall street world that
already have decades of experience and
reputation and trust built around it
they have kind of regulatory licenses
they have private relationships etc
but the majority of people who are
already in they ain't going to use these
products right they don't they're not
waiting around for a bank to show up
with a custody product they've said to
themselves either i'm going to
self-custody it or i'm going to use one
of the crypto native uh firms and so i
think that what we're watching here is
just like we had the infrastructure get
built to get the crypto audience in or
the bitcoin audience in uh if you go all
the way back to 2011 2012 it was really
hard to buy bitcoin really hard to store
it right really hard to mine it et
cetera then we had a bunch of
infrastructure built that allowed for
individuals and uh uh kind of retail to
come into the market now what we're
watching is we're watching the
institutional infrastructure get built
that's going to bring in the
institutions there's kind of a cohort
adoption you get the individuals first
then you get institutions then you get
nation states in the institution you
both get public corporations or private
corporations and you get financial
institutions and what we're watching is
simultaneously that institution cohort
is exploding in adoption we've seen
obviously all the banks all the
financial asset managers etc now what
we're starting to see is who are the
bank customers right u.s bank doesn't
have a bunch of hedge funds as their
customers they have companies they have
foundations they have other types of
organizations those are the people
getting in the game now and it's
continued to provide this persistent uh
kind of uh demand as a tailwind for the
asset and it's gonna obviously lead to
uh pretty rapid price appreciation fifth
largest retail bank in the us yeah so
it's just crazy to think about they're
starting to play remember coinbase has
more users than uh charles swapp
right so again anybody who's watching
this if you work at an incumbent firm
and you're not in the game get moving
because you're going to miss this entire
thing and what we're watching is every
single day in in the month of july
remember those numbers off the top of my
head 1.2 million new entities came onto
the bitcoin blockchain they didn't come
onto the blockchain via coinbase they
didn't come on through any sort of
traditional financial firm they didn't
come through uh any of your legacy
marketing channels et cetera that came
directly onto the blockchain you are not
only competing with your incumbent peers
you're not only competing with the
crypto native firms you're also
competing with the direct access to a
decentralized open monetary network and
so what we saw was twitter earlier this
year literally just turn on that open
monetary network and now their 300 plus
million users are able to access and use
that and they never had to open another
account that is the entire value
proposition of this asset